today's episode is brought to you by
gray block pizza gray block pizza 18:11
Pico Boulevard on the way to the beach
in Los Angeles gray block get that
hitter let's get in here with a little
bit of gun
I've seen home in about a hundred days I
can almost hear mama bleep for my
restless soul and now he made a dollar
night spell but where it's going ain't
kill me yet I still get wet I'm bound go
you
we can roll right
[Music]
they're making their time
you know what man that's a little too
slow for me at the moment dude let me
back out of that one
and let's just get right into to that
hitter
[Music]
I want to get a harmonica told you we
should get one I'm just sitting on your
front porch wandering how could I be so
far oh come on and my mind is somewhere
else but when I found it our patch up
where it's been grown don't be too cool
to sing with it man come on get out of
that
[Music]
little time for me to sell that pocket
break
and let myself all my shine
[Music]
just that is shine by Bishop gun and you
know what this boys are touring Europe
right now I think about that I think
about you know a couple of long-haired
Nair do wells and decently do Wells
trawl up and around Europe with their
instruments and they're you know they've
probably been up all night you know
doing music and drinking liquor and
trying to learn German or whatever and
I'll just picture those boys just
[ __ ] living their lives over there
and that's exciting that's exciting man
I hope they're over there doing all kind
of just living doing drugs sex rock and
roll and living hard and if you have
never never seen Bishop Gunn
there on a European tour right now and I
do recommend checking them out they do
not pay for this service from me they
are friends of mine and and when I
listen to their music it makes me feel
good oh thank you guys thanks for being
here what am i doing I am sitting here
in the studio and do my shirt I kind of
wore a short shirt you ever freaking
leave the house in a short shirt dang
man like if your shirt is regular you
never even think about it if it's a good
length I got to have a specificall
length shirt to feel my own self comfort
because if I have too long of a shirt I
feel like I'm like one of the um you
know Seven Dwarfs that one that's always
sleepy you know dozer or whatever his
name is you know who I'm gonna [ __ ]
know what they are now sneezy a dozy or
something you know one of them or if
it's too short I feel like a damn little
I feel like a little [ __ ] white
chocolate Hershey kiss that somebody's
trying to like a little kind of
gentleman trying to meet other gentlemen
out there on you know under a porch
lighter under a lamp you know under a
big tall city lamp but that's you know
if it's too short I'm just that is you
know that makes me so I just like God I
just don't know what's going on I just
feel like my butt cheeks don't even know
each other when I have a real short
shirt on I just feel uncomfortable I
feel strikingly uncomfortable when I'm
in a short shirt so this one's a little
short you can't see because I'm sitting
down and well it doesn't even really
matter so whatever good to be here with
you I am you know I'm about you know
well I'm about maybe 90 days off at a
pornography right now and that's cool
that's pretty you know I feel good about
myself for that now I'm still an open
you know I've open up some snapchats and
got some wild coot
you know just that's the thing about
snapchat snapchat
that's like Pandora's boxing glove you
know you open it up and bite out
something you know Pandora the you know
Satan's little daughter Pandora just hit
you with it damn you know it could be
anything
you know some guys sleeping at work or a
cooter punch just a random cooter
somebody's sending you through the
airwaves some [ __ ] airwave cooter
just hit you right out of that snapchat
is very dangerous snapchat it's like
it's like monkeying around powerlines
you ever seen the commercials they used
to have with the monkey and you think
he's safe and everything and he's just
hanging out
but then he grabs that power line and
kills himself and that's like paid
that's like a snapchat you think it
might be you know open it up it's gonna
be could be a couple cookies or you know
little you know little daniels out there
[ __ ] you know shining up his
rollerskates and he's ready to do
something you know just like a little do
a little sidewalk adventure in the
neighborhood
you know ready to just kind of cruise
past the little girls that selling
girl-scout cookies but then you open up
that next snapchat and it's some girl
giving that bgz out there you know out
there outside of Philadelphia
or something one of them Turnpike bee
gees and it's uh it's very alarming you
never know what you're gonna get it's
like going door-to-door in a haunted
house and sometimes things aren't that
haunted it's just some guy crying or
something you know and he just bought a
plant and he's you know it could be
somebody has a flat tire somebody
singing happy birthday to their little
cousin but then BAM somebody hit you
with that freestyle coochie out the
thing you like jeepers is this what you
know is just what we want is this what
the Lord wants I don't know I don't know
but I'm feeling good about being off
that pornography man I feel good you
know I didn't know how I first of all I
couldn't do it if it wasn't for you know
I put these apps on my phone mobis sip
and covenant eyes on my computer so
those two apps one on each and it just
prevents it so I don't feel the need to
do it or if I you know I got in this bad
habit of just jerking out at night and
getting my body to just make magic you
know just make that magic [ __ ]
saltwater at night and I got kind of
used to it and and it used to be fun I
used to be on being sexual and being
naughty you know sometime I would put
both my hands together and make love to
my hands like that in the middle of them
like I had you know and pretend my hands
had like a little name like Samantha or
something but after that it just became
just this one-handed you know crazy guy
and I would just kind of get my own
wiener out at night and just just not
even give it a chance to really think
about much and just you just you know
just end up kind of jerking out
so I'm glad I'm just and I've just broke
the habit that's what it was it was bad
habit so now I'll still do masturbation
I'll still do self masturbation
sometimes but I'm not doing it just as a
nightly weird habit and I've noticed
that I just feel better I feel I just
feel a little bit more in control I
don't feel like I as obsessed with sex
or thinking about you know no hmm-hmm
you know or anything like that or you
know like I won't be at the arm you know
sometimes you'll be somewhere and
something will remind you of something
sexual you'll be at the fair and you see
like a funnel cake here like damn that
thing looks like a pretty you know kind
of like a fried little yeah you know but
I'm not having any thoughts like that
now I'm just more because my brain isn't
thinking sex first it's just thinking
about other stuff and it's giving my
brain more space to think so it's it's
been undo if you listen to the first you
know 120 episodes of the podcast it's
really about me trying not to watch
pornography and struggling and just to
not have that struggle in my life and
it's so quickly it went away for years
it was this weird cycle that was in my
head you know just like oh I'm lonesome
I feel uncomfortable I better you know
touch you know make sure my Weiner still
you know is at least on my team that's
kind of how it was sometimes I think I
would even masturbate because it was
like well if the world you know at least
if I jerk my cell at least you know my
Weiner I'm gonna prove that my Weiner
something is on my team and I don't have
a puppy or like a wife or anything like
that so it would just be the closest
thing I could reach really especially if
you're lazy and that's your ween that's
that we mean boy
so feeling excited about that
the other day I was on Twitter and
accidentally went on a page that had
something sexual and shut it down quick
but it's nice it used to be I'd be in
the fruit section at the grocery
and everything in now I'm thinking dang
bro I'm not trying to be sexual but you
know a lot of these you know kind of mid
to larger size vegetables look like they
want to [ __ ] you know I mean you see a
dang you know you see a decent yellow
squash over your there you like damn it
that [ __ ] [ __ ] is trying to back
that thing up you get different ideas
you know you see a couple of plums kind
of huddled together you're like holy
smokes these plums wants a foursome you
know where you get these wild ideas but
the other day I went through the produce
section I don't anything about anything
I just thought about well you know well
you know maybe I'll have a salad soon so
it's nice to just be having regular
thoughts and just have gotten out of
that expanse in my mind that you know
that kind of dirty road that my mind was
going down a lot of times what else is
going on with me oh I'm going to Boston
well I'm going to New York this week on
Wednesday and I'm going to do two
barstool radio so that should be pretty
cool I have not spent any time with
those guys and what else this week am I
going and doing want to tape something
tomorrow that should be pretty cool you
know if you like hot sauce it'll be good
so kind of like nervous and excited
about you know things I don't like to
you know I don't like to sometimes get
too excited because you know you just
don't want to get your hopes up you know
my shoulders are sore sometimes from
keeping my hopes up so I like to try and
keep things a little bit level but also
to try and just enjoy what's going on
and be excited and we got the Andrew
Schultz episode if you haven't met this
bad cracker he's out of Manhattan and
he's just living free man and he's doing
it his way and he came in studio we're
gonna put that out this week and it was
awesome and he's a neat man we're
excited it was cool to have him
be around him what else is happening man
I got uh what else is going on with me
not much I've been trying to focus on
like going to some different meetings
you know I go to these sobriety meetings
going to some of that and and I'm just
trying to feel a little bit more like
myself I got on the chantix so a little
scary if you haven't taken chantix it
feels like a really weak person is
trying to hold on to your lungs
sometimes you know like trying to hold
your lungs that's what it feels like and
it feels like a couple children that
haven't been fed very much they have
eaten okay we're not starving these
children in my imagination but they
haven't eaten much it feel like they're
kind of holding onto your lungs and
don't you know not letting you inhale
very much and that's what it feels like
and it makes the taste of a cigarette
like unenjoyable and that's when I think
about it for me cigarettes have been
unenjoyable for a while I doesn't want
to be addicted I don't know if one day I
might I want to enjoy a cigarette I just
don't want to feel like I have to enjoy
a cigarette to be okay or to get through
a moment and I don't like thinking about
cigarettes I'm gonna be able to enjoy
the moment that I'm in in my life
because I'll do do it I'll look I'll go
I'll be on a waterslide and I'll write
I'll be about to get on that [ __ ] and
my mind I'm like it'll say a little
trickery to me say hey little fella with
that little wet body if you go down this
slide and you're and you're well-behaved
you can have a you a little cigarette at
the bottom
and that's when my mind telling me stuff
like that so so yeah you know I'm trying
to just be more active and take action
and make somebody you know make some of
the changes I've been thinking about for
a long time and and that feels pretty
cool what else did I do this weekend do
not I was up at the Comedy Store you
know a lot of people are still I've
still been talking about Brody Stephens
and you know and losing Brody and and a
friend of mine went to clean out his
apartment or not clean it out not steal
nothing but just be a part of you know -
you know taking you know taking down his
things and you know cuz somebody has to
clean up when you pass away somebody has
to clean up and you know he was telling
he was saying man it's amazing how much
stuff people have and he was saying to
say how interesting it was that you know
Brody didn't have like a Canon same
amount but he had a lot and it just it
made me think like man when I leave when
I leave the earth I think about all the
things I'm gonna leave behind that
somebody's gonna have to freakin deal
with it made me think almost I want a
booby-trap some [ __ ] you know
you know paja - [ __ ] mousetrap and a
thing of um you know cotton so
somebody's reaching they're like all
this a softbox what's in here maybe a
little Vaz or some you know some
different type of treasure
BAM [ __ ] pain that's what's in
that box
I'm going to Boston this week I'm one in
New York for one night on Wednesday and
then I'm gonna go to Boston
Thursday Medford if you have not been to
the show it's at the chevalier Theatre
in Medford San Jose sold-out that's in a
couple weeks and more tickets will be
coming on sale I believe maybe even
today for that Australia everybody's
been asking and we're gonna add some
more shows over there I don't know where
they're gonna be I don't know what's
gonna happen we're figuring it out right
now and when I say we I just mean me
really and just the calendar it's kind
of it and just how much I can do
also March 29th and 30th I'm at stand-up
live in Phoenix Arizona April 5th and
six Kansas City improv Kansas City
Missouri about to add some more shows
for that and April 26 and April 27th the
Palm Beach improv in West Palm Beach
Florida May 3rd and 4th at Caroline's in
New York City and I just want to say
thank you you know for everybody that's
been listening to the podcast and paying
attention and you know I've been
thinking a lot about this week about how
you know really just how lucky I am and
a lot of times I come in here and I
complain about what's going on in my
life and you know I don't mean to
complain I just you know I have a tough
time in the regular world I have a tough
time in it and and for me that's just
the way I operate you know you ever seen
a do with no legs on the [ __ ] on a
bike and that's me that's how I operate
in the world it's just it takes a little
it takes a lot for me to feel okay and
you guys have done that man you guys
have been so supportive so I just want
to thank you and and I'm ready a man I'm
ready - I'm ready to do my best I'm
ready to entertain at a good level and
make people and just bring it and just
you know I'm ready to bring the power
and make us have fun and help and be a
part of having fun and you guys have
been just so supportive and it just it
it means a lot you know I'm getting to
live my dream out you know I'm getting
to live my dream and I can't like
there's no way I could do that by myself
so thank you a couple of news things
that I did Arad started on Saturday and
if you're not familiar with the Iditarod
you know it's um
Alaska Alaska day I think if you up
there long enough you get a little
probably lazy you know or just snowed in
and so you hire a [ __ ] bunch of dogs
to pull you across the continent and
these dogs man these are some real
Wolf's dogs Wolf's probably a [ __ ]
skinny bear with a big nose you know all
kind of animals a [ __ ] fox that's on
HGH who knows what they you know what
Mother Nature is serving up there
I mean Alaska is like the like the
icebox it's a it's like the freezer
section of a mare of the really of
America and the world think about it
your memory when you in the grocery you
in regular sections you're walking
around and got the Ritz crackers you
know somebody put a thing of pickled
cabbages or something little you know
those little what does it call with the
butter fingers they got those beautiful
I [ __ ] used to [ __ ] eat a
Butterfinger right when I get to the
grocery boy dude it if I ain't buying
this [ __ ] son of meat and I'm hiding a
wrapper under a couple cabbages over
there by the produce areas but here's
what I'm saying is remember when you're
walking through the grocery everything's
casual and they got them some more you
know those are you know with the arm
with the little guys that live in the
trees the arm
then cobbler ELLs boy dem crackers they
got them little crackers they got the
raisins Raisinets some of the [ __ ]
came out with Raisinets do you know a
feminist probably couldn't handle
raisins
just doing their thing because they used
to have a little dance team and stuff on
television and somebody came out with
Raisinets and that's some bad [ __ ] in
a bag right there and they ain't [ __ ]
around but but anyway you cruisin
through everything is warm it's
comfortable cozy and then you get to the
freezer section do you could lose a
friend in the [ __ ] freezer section of
the grocery when you were kid and you
walk in and you're like suddenly your
mom opens that thing and as I walk you
don't know what's going on you can't
remember who both your parents are your
eyes don't work that good your [ __ ]
shoulders turn all red you get nervous
and just because your mom wants to get a
couple of seconds and if we do this
crazy back in there in the freezer
section man anything they got you know
and you hope it's ice cream but it's not
your mom's getting them teriyaki meals
over there some [ __ ] [ __ ] you
know lean Gene Okerlund cuisine you know
these little 60 calories and then look
it's served in the damn half of a
[ __ ] Space Shuttle the thing just you
know everything got does that Zekey
sauce on it and you're losing your
[ __ ] mind bro that freezer second
make you what do it oh I would I would
put on a couple coats for I go on the
into the frozen food area when you're a
kid and you reach over then he said that
big part with the big turkeys and the
chickens in there that [ __ ] used to be
freezing when I was a kid now it's like
safety precautions and this and that and
you know the dead animals don't even
like to be at real cold temperatures
because they little [ __ ] but when I
was young man I'm turkey doesn't thing
was that four degrees in there you reach
over there and catch one of them
butterball hitters
did I remember I turned there ever one
time one of the turkey had been you know
it was dead it was like man [ __ ] cold
damn they serving him up but the
Iditarod is that they put these cold
dogs out there and these [ __ ]
run to a fire they put a fire you know I
mean it's a thousand mile race so they
put a thought they put a fire a thousand
miles from these dogs and they so they
so cold they'll run to that [ __ ]
and there's 52 teams 14 dogs on each
team do you know I'd be that dog out
there at night Ron oh boy waking up the
other dogs you know I'm saying rolling a
little [ __ ] pork cutlet over by a
little wall you know maybe by a little
one you know a Weimaraner or something
you get that bad [ __ ] get you know they
got a couple female German Shepherds out
there and they say they into some wild
[ __ ] I've seen them on the Internet and
off we're gonna roll a pork cutlet over
there with my chin and forgive that
[ __ ] that cut but you know and then I
you know while she's giving it while
she's enjoying that cutlet I give her
that rib you feel me
you know what I'm saying that thirty
first rib baby that wiener but it takes
nine days apparently it starts in Willow
Alaska it finishes in Nome Alaska
it takes nine days $50,000 for the
winter and and I bet that's pretty
exciting you know if I were somebody who
was crazy I would hide some hamburger
meat in the snow and watch the whole
[ __ ] race go AWOL son did you hide a
[ __ ] um one of those water burgers in
there
dude a dog will go probably at least 200
yards off track for a Down water burger
but that's the Iditarod it's a special
thing you can wear your snow equipment
it's probably dudes looking for women
I mean Alaska is the kind of place
you'll go a thousand miles you know just
because you heard a titty upwind do you
know that's Alaska you know I'm saying
they have rumors even if you hear even a
rumor that somebody gave birth to twin
girls you'll you know you'll drive over
just to you know drop a gift off for the
ladies just in case you meet them 18
years later when everybody's a legal age
to date and to talk and to have you know
gin and tonics so it's different out
there what else Steven Speilberg wants
to keep Netflix and other streaming
platforms from having their films
considered for the Oscars spielberg has
made it clear in the past that he thinks
Netflix films qualify only as TV movies
fit for fit for Emmy consideration and
not as films you know this is really
interesting because I've thought that a
little bit that Netflix starts to feel
kind of stale it just starts to feel
like everything is sort of the same you
know what I'm saying it's like you ever
see that Cisco truck they have the Cisco
truck it's always out back of a
restaurant and they always they got
everything in there everything from you
know little you could get anything you
want little you know Veals little you
know veal squares or whatever um what
else
grapes napkins everything but you can
order it all from this one company so at
a certain point everything is just from
the same place at all you know it all
kind of just feels the same a little bit
and I think that way about Netflix
sometimes it's it kind of loses some of
its identity because everything on there
I'm just like oh this is just another
Netflix movie it is different and it
feels different so that's interesting
point cuz I've thought that I'm like ah
you know a lot of these movies is just
like is that really a movie or is
just you know some [ __ ] long
television that they made I think it
doesn't feel like a movie especially I
think maybe to me in my generation
because for movies for us they started
in the theater and these movies aren't
starting in the theater and so it's
coming to on your small screen on your
computer first so it probably does have
that different vibe but Netflix
everything just starts to feel like oh
here's a show here's a show this this
this for some reason it all kind of has
a little bit of this same film on it
like it was all just brought over by the
same Cisco truck or was you ever get an
egg somewhere or a piece of um you ever
get a french fry at a restaurant and
they cook it next to the fish or in the
same oil like you'll have a french fry
on you like Dan a fry got a little bit
of carp in the back of it well that is
what I'm talking about Netflix
everything have that little bit of fish
taste in it so I get that vibe so I I
have to agree with Spielberg after
groups be Steve Steve
stem Steven Spielberg I met some of the
complaints are there about the streaming
services how much they spend on Oscar
marketing campaigns so they're saying
that oh these people are just spending
all this money on this marketing to get
these awards and then they are then they
aren't even you know the the movies
aren't even in theaters where people can
see them in that facet you know I'll say
this to what a lot of people don't
realize is you know they put these
movies out they put all these kind of
fancy sort of what I think user not even
that good a movies out around the Oscars
times I mean movies have got nothing bad
like I felt like when I was younger a
movie was a real deal you know it was
sorry getting over bronchitis you know a
movie was just a different thing it was
um there was something to it it was I
don't know it just felt like it was
always going to be good and now you can
make a bad movie and the company that
funded the movie also owns the
advertising you know the PR companies so
then they have their own company write
an article under a different name and
put it out and say hey this is a great
movie when they know it's not they don't
care they don't care what else what else
is going mmm
[Music]
Bryce Harper signed a three hundred
thirty million dollar contract with the
Philadelphia Phillies can you imagine
that money three hundred and thirty
million with the do you go by can you
buy Philadelphia for that you could at
least buy Punxsutawney PA and own that
little durable I would do with that much
money again how you not gonna do cocaine
how soon do you all want this guy doing
cocaine because you telling me this
Bryce Harper's gots 330 mm million
dollars dude there's no way I'm putting
1 million of that towards the great
white north you know what I'm saying
that [ __ ] knows Alaska baby yeah
I'm [ __ ] that Pablo Escobar's baby I
buy a [ __ ] straight-up swig gallon of
cocaine have anybody ever bought a
gallon of cocaine because that's what I
would be oh yeah let me get a uhm glad
bag full of cocaine also fill up my
[ __ ] hat while you're at it just yeah
oh no don't feel it today or fill it put
that you know give me that mogul baby
throw that freaking us that [ __ ]
dusty snout chowder on there because I'm
looking for the Lord you feel me I think
it's too much money to give someone at
once
it doesn't seem safe so let's see what
happens to him Bryce Harper taking that
what I like to call the cocaine
challenge you got three hundred and
thirty million dollars do it I would
have a stripper dancing on each shoulder
a really small stripper you know so you
could just look over like that and smell
him tain't pants
you know feel me smell them [ __ ] milk
bungalows baby so I'm just welcome to
what I like to call the cocaine
challenge Bryce Harper you got three
hundred thirty million dollars then I
get my nuts gold-plated boy when I sat
down you would hear a thing
when I sat in any chair like what was
that something wrong with the chair naw
something's right with my nuts I got
these 14 karat gonads bruh and daddy's
thing ready to do business the good luck
Bryce Harper I'm sorry I'm sniffling I
feel like I've been on the Iditarod I'm
sorry that I'm sick I hope you guys
aren't sick I know a lot of people been
going around and getting sick and if you
are getting sick I'm sorry about that
now I gotta let you guys know about a
real hitter
it's that bottom hitter cleanser it's
called bad elegance but elegance but
delegates it's that natural cleansing
foam that brings you the
the luxury and elegance of a bidet with
the convenience a toilet paper
a bidet will wash your butt for you it's
like a French person spitting on your
butt but now but delegates really has
cornered that market it's that natural
cleansing foam it's better than both dry
toilet paper and it's better than wet
wipes it's cost effective it's
anti-inflammatory it's soothing it keeps
your hands dry it does not harm the
sewer system and it's eco-friendly
here's an amazon review from a tpw
listener Marrissa 5 out of 5 stars
elegance February 14 2019 I purchased
this product due to Theo von
recommending this to me on his podcast
this past weekend he said that if I
couldn't afford a bad day that but
d'Elegance would be the next best option
and I can't afford a bidet well I
currently rent my residence and I don't
think my landlord of the HOA would be
happy with me installing one that's true
zoning issues plus my bathroom is tiny
and I would not have anywhere to put it
unless I pulled out the shower that's
insane
Marissa anyway I'm cleaner than ever
thanks but elegance and Theo von and
that is a real Amazon review Wow nice to
know they got a lady running around
clean out there thanks to ya boy
and ye abide elegance but elegance is
available right now on amazon.com for
10% off and free shipping use promo code
1-0 Theo von that's 10 the number 10
Theo von for 10% off and free shipping
used 10 Theo von when you check out and
buy bad elegance on amazon.com and now
back to the episode we had Dane Cook in
studio that was interesting
you know Damian is an interesting dude
man I didn't I mean he really I think he
just connects with the world differently
I think he's always been like this guy
you got a you know who had a lot to
prove to himself which I can relate to
and I can understand and we all can
probably
and I just think I don't think he you
know I think the world is kind of like
this this if the world is like this
purple he's kind of like this blue and
this red and he is of the world but he's
also he's different he just doesn't mix
with it as smoothly as others do you
know it was interesting you know he
talks about like Brotherhood and this
comedy Brotherhood but he never seems to
be in that he always seems to just be
doing his own thing but I don't think he
does it on purpose I think it's just the
way that he interacts with the world but
also what the [ __ ] do I know you know
I'm just sharing my experience so but I
was glad that he came in it was you know
that's the most I've ever talked to him
by far you know a lot of guys you speak
with them a decent amount and then you
know he kind of just does his own thing
you know he just kind of does his own
thing but he's a funny man and he's had
some very unique experiences that many
in the world will never have baby we got
a couple calls that came in I want to
take a few let's get this hitter right
here
hae-jin thank you for calling and thank
you to everybody in Houston I you know I
I know last week I just talked about
Brody a lot and man it was a special
time I had a great time beautiful club
I'd go back guys I would shoot a special
there sometime or record an album and I
kind of wish that I had but thank you
guys so much
onward I'm calling to let you know that
my soon to be eggs dude and I were at
the show on Saturday oh wow so I hope I
didn't hope I didn't say anything to
just hope y'all parted ways amicably
because I thought it was a good show and
it was awesome I mean your hair to see
it and that's cool glory is just
something to behold
oh thank you and that's how it is you
know that front that's uh that's the
front is really
that's that I got that flower in the
front I got that power in the back baby
you know I got that sprout and I got
that spout you feel me I got that reach
and I got that teach in the back you
know so a lot of things like a lot of
time I'll peek my head out in the
[ __ ] raccoon you didn't even know it
been living around your house you'll
[ __ ] show up you know animals want to
[ __ ] when I really get mine when I take
a hat off animals want to [ __ ] but thank
you for the compliment um thank you for
coming thank you for coming back we
appreciate you know everything that you
do and your show is amazing I learn a
lot and I feel a lot and yeah I'm like
[ __ ] that gave you the the Dean Martin
roast of Michael Landon so I hope you
like it anyway you know Gang Gang Gang
Gang lovely yeah I did get that I don't
have a DVD player at the moment so I
have some DVDs I'm still been meaning to
watch I got a um somebody sent me some
photos from a wedding in December I got
a watch I want to watch you know what
else do I have uh Saving Private Ryan
and then I'm gonna watch that that uh
roast of Michael Landon roast by Dean
Martin that you gave me and thank you
very sweet of you and I do remember that
sorry I'm still a little sick but thank
you for that as always if you are
dealing with something or want to share
something or struggling with something
you can hit the hotline nine eight five
six six four nine five zero three
you know this podcast is some time as
its well who knows what it is it is what
it is so you know I'm not trying to put
it in a box I mean [ __ ] I'm just happy
that we're still going I'm very grateful
for that
oh I do wanna let you know this we try
to do a single mom in Houston and she
had to cancel so she had to cancel and
this is the second time that happened in
a row to us there was it was Columbus
and Houston that both the single moms
had to can
so almost the day before so last minute
and so we had to you know we couldn't do
it we didn't do it so we'll be finding
some of these upcoming cities if you
have a single mom that you think would
be good to come out in San Jose or in
Phoenix or Tempe Arizona please hit the
hotline nine eight five six six four
nine five zero three this doesn't need
to be your girlfriend it's nobody like
that this isn't your mother we're
looking for a woman who has young
children who could use who's a hard
worker who could use a night out you
know we want to make you know we just
want to make them have what we want to
help them have fun be a part of it and
and we want them we'll pay for the
sitter but we still donated on some
money to the mother from Houston to do
something nice with her children and I
want to thank our patreon supporters for
that let's take another call
Phyllis vo from Indiana woe from India
dang boy that's condiment country India
a lot of time in India they don't have
meat so they don't have meat you might
get some cracker and they don't have
meat on it instead they put sauce color
that's it mm-hmm cuz after me comes
sauce and if they don't have meat BAM
[ __ ] straight to sauce that's
India
that's condiment country they'll put
anything on the damn cracker bro green
spice red spice and you trying them in
like over you have you had this yellow
[ __ ] spice Oh
welcome to India oh you tried the green
in the red and the yellow have you had
this [ __ ] base paisa what about this
have you had this [ __ ] orange spice
sauce you're like Jesus I can't even
feel my damn face anymore and they're
like yeah you're in India
watch your face [ __ ] burn while a
monkey sneaks up and picks your pocket
and that's India man beautiful country
beautiful people I mean just and the
smiles on the faces of the children
there and
there when I was a student for a week
and uh I mean it's just no plumbing but
goddamn I mean the but I mean you could
you know it's kind of it's this country
you kind of just want to flush the
handle once and just get all uh you know
get everything out of there and you know
get all the they got a lot of just loose
duty I mean you'll see you know you'll
see a kid in his buddy just humming a
little you know humming a little TR
doubt their turd just throwing it back
and forth you're like damn what are they
doing or don't we shooting marbles with
a little hard in the little goose
pellets little duties from goose that's
India but let's hear more on word just
what's real but you're okay episode I
just want to say and then you always
talk about you on this field okay and
you know I'm sorry about your friend the
pathways I think a lot of us had that
and a lot of your your things and the
people that call in want to tell you do
you are okay it is that empathy and
compassion that you show for everybody
that's what makes you a pen man and you
need to find a way to quantify that in
your life and and do you okay with that
find a piece and Goering men appreciate
that you know it's funny you say that
because I've been thinking about that
you know I uh sorry eyes had to swallow
some mucus but you have been thinking
about
you know at some point in my life I have
to get on through these this stuff these
feelings of what you know what makes you
know the feelings of inadequacy the
feelings I have to but I think sometimes
it's a it's a it's a never-ending kind
of competition because it's just
something that's in me and for me that's
my alcoholism
you know that's this thing inside of me
that will never be it'll never be really
a solid foundation but I have I can
learn to work with it better and that's
what I'm trying to learn right now is
just tools to work with it better but
thank you for saying that man you know
sometimes yeah it's like I feel like I'm
not okay but really if I ask myself I
just feel this invisible it's almost
like a bunch of bees buzzing around you
know and it's just this little this
weird energy that's just around me that
something is wrong and it's inside of me
to it they're under my skin and it's in
me and it's just you know it's just a
discomfort and I think sometimes I have
to constantly try and do things that
that showed me in front of my face that
I am like if I don't do
in front of me that I won't feel it
inside of me you know and it's just the
way that I interact with the world
sometimes but thank you man thank you
for saying that you know I just I really
I thought a lot about that when Brody
took his own life and I just made me
think you know so often we have this
world where people if somebody isn't
okay they can't say it and in sometimes
we feel like we have to know exactly
what's wrong and that I guess that's
kind of more what I was thinking about
is you don't if you're not okay you can
just say hey you know I'm not okay I
don't even know what's wrong with me but
I'm just not okay because I think that
that's a feeling that a lot of people
can really relate to but that's nice you
to call and get that message and I give
that message to uh I'm gonna reflect
that message back out to anybody else
out there that's feeling like they're
not enough right now or just feeling
that they're not man you're okay I
promise if you listen in to this [ __ ]
[ __ ] then you're probably okay if you're
not okay go listen to Chris D'Elia go
listen to you know Bobby Lee that wild
little [ __ ] Viet bruh that dude Jesus
Christ bro I mean somebody said you
could draw his penis and like less than
a second so he gots really a unique
wiener but if you're not okay there's
things you know you can listen to these
guys and they'll make you laugh that's
what I mean but thank you for the nice
message let's take another call yo
what's good do she's [ __ ] Stan of the
podcast
anyways get straight to the point gang
[ __ ] gang gang gang daddy and you
calling out there and you sound like you
might be on some uppers or downers right
now you might be on a little [ __ ] a
couple handfuls a sidewinder son and I
ain't mad at you homework alright so my
name is William Reese I'm a full-blood
made of American I live oh hell yeah
dude welcome back man I want to say that
on behalf of everybody you know people
think every
you know you know people's mad about the
fights or whatever that happened Dances
with Wolves and all that [ __ ]
dude I say welcome back so you know
we're good
onward I live in Oklahoma and I'm part
of the Kickapoo tribe wow man that's
beautiful dude somebody in my family was
part Native American or Indian they
called it but I'm not sure who it was
let's hear more and I've been really
digging the stick ass larger you know
we've been talking for about two months
now and like I just liked I wanna maker
100% mine dang boy you talkin about that
[ __ ] you talking about reeling in
there whitey huh we got a Native
American right here [ __ ] Kickapoo
Kenny over here but the wheel and that
white girl dude that's what I'm talking
about beige power son you know what I'm
saying that cross-pollination dude you
know I'm saying dot that feather bro do
it do we do it
but be careful here's what I'm saying
you got to read these history books man
I remember cuz the history books you
know a lot of native dudes they went for
that white you know that white you know
they saw that white salmon that sexy
white salmon flopping in a distance and
y'all went over there you know to put it
in your basket and you got the syphilis
or somebody came and stabbed or whatever
or you lost the battle but so just be
careful you know I would make sure her
intention she don't have any you know
her cousin ain't waiting over the ledge
to pounce on you you know I know it was
different times back then and it was
just when things were more you know
colonial people just stealing each
other's land
I mean people was just you know it was
still [ __ ] New Jack city and times are
different now and if you you know it
seemed like you probably know we're good
if y'all are in love but you know I
would glance out a couple history books
bull run what else french-indian war
French American War whatever
and look [ __ ] the French brah so that's
definite and we all know that isn't that
crazy even Native Americans no [ __ ] the
French the French dude what have they
done bro made hats yeah so and made
cheese different cheese is hard to
pronounce so anyway let's hear more from
you all word a but my grandma she's very
cold rural and traditional and she like
to stick to our ways without respect
you know but she's kind of against it
because she's scared we will lose our
bloodline you know being full Native
American then a boy and it's crazy
because Native American that na also
means Narcotics Anonymous and sometimes
you know you know you'll see a Cherokee
just you know run over and just hatch it
right into a bottle of gin you know what
I'm saying all we know so many of us are
around the mean itit states anymore you
know hmm
but anyways yes where can I kind of meet
my grandmother in the middle right or
should I go - as far as giving up on
this white girl this huge-ass I had for
some solid advice mr. Yvonne thank you
for the call that's sweet of you to call
in let me get your name again yo look
good Theo
Hughes [ __ ] fan of the podcast
anyways get straight to the point okay
she didn't give it but thank you for the
call brother and moon brother I think I
should say you know moon brother land
brother all of that River you know River
buddy everything I want to do total you
know I'm supportive of you guys and you
know someone in my family I think it on
my father's side was something Cherokee
you know percent Aztec or something I
don't know I gotta
I've got to look through the charts and
everything but it's a great question you
know what do you do if you want you know
because that has to be kind of a unique
experience because you're exploiting do
you have bro let me tell you this every
time I'm very sorry about that
you have your right man you have a real
you got that you know you got that
Aquafina and then you know you got that
white girl over there with that thick
[ __ ] Evian boy and y'all trying to
stream team so and this [ __ ] ain't
really h2 okay with your grandmother
you know she likes that [ __ ]
authentic drip she likes that Folgers
and you rollin in here trying to [ __ ]
spice up into those Keurig cups so I
think I think one of the first thing you
could do is just have her spend time
with the young lady you know because I
believe that you know I believe that it
it probably would take a real experience
more than you just convincing her you
know if you can have if you can help
them have a real experience together you
know maybe you guys could all you know
maybe you could have a traditional meal
and you know have your grandmother
explain to the young lady what these
different foods you know mean or where
the recipes come from cuz yeah I mean
you look with the blood you got in you
right now
you got pure Native American blood dude
out you could probably sell four pints
of that to Joe Rogan on the dark web I
mean Brian and Brandon fighter in the
comm canary they'll [ __ ] buy do you
they would be brother they'll sip
they'll sip that stuff out right out of
your tailpipe you got that from the
earth you got that salty drip I mean you
got [ __ ] birds in your blood daddy
you got that snake hitter
and they want that [ __ ] you got that
powwow boy but I think it's nice that
you actually first of all I think is
nice you have concern for your
grandmother that you respect what she
thinks and it is important these days I
think it's really important people want
to think like you know I don't think
there's anything wrong with taking that
much pride in your culture where if you
wanted to say you know I want to have a
child that is this then that's okay it
doesn't mean you don't want to do other
things it just means that that's your
preference but you've been tempted by
that white thick thick you know you've
been tempted by that [ __ ] in that loud
loud bra like somebody just blew two
white [ __ ] two milky creamy you know
two big vape circles right next to each
other and that's that white ass that
fancy white ass coming over the hillside
and that kind of struggle wagon and you
get over there and you snacking on it
and having a little tasty taste and then
BAM boy [ __ ] you know you know couple
dudes couple young you know her little
cousins sneak out the back with that
thing a gunpowder so man what would I do
here if I was in love with someone of a
different race or ethnicity or culture
and I was scared of what my family would
think I think yet doing heaven maybe
maybe see if you know I mean I think it
would be a lot but I think it would be
really really cool if you learn some
traditional things from your grandmother
or took some of her experiences and see
how if you're this girl you care about
let her know how much it means that your
grandmother means this much to you and
it means as much as you honor some of
their traditions and see what her
thoughts are on it the young lady might
have some ideas oh well this should be
really cool what if we did this and we
you know I was in up in st. Cloud
Minnesota one time or Minnetonka and
they had a minnetonka tribe up there and
and I went to a festival they had and it
was amazing
man seeing the beadwork and seeing the a
lot of the family fun you know the
little children the Papoose is bruh and
the little pep boots or whatever the
boys just seeing them playing that fun
and just you know with that culture and
it's beautiful you know just a beautiful
a lot of Native Americans I mean there's
beautiful hair beautiful skin tone so
yeah it's it is important it's important
that you're thinking about it that's a
good question for our listeners
you know I've no I haven't been in a lot
of interracial relationships I do think
about it sometimes you know I think
about adopting like um kids uh not like
I want kids of other ethnicities but I
have these you know a lot of times
visions come into my life that are you
know I think from a higher power and I
think that and a lot of those have come
true in my life and and sometimes I have
a vision of me raising like a Hispanic
kid and that may sound crazy or you know
because I know that if you know my
higher power if God's gonna bless me
with you know the ability to take care
of you know to feed a family and to feed
myself and then I can help someone else
you know I know that I you know I
believe that I could do that I don't
know that I could but sometimes I'm
hopeful that I could and so sometimes
this vision I have a vision of having my
own family but then I'm also having an
inclusion into my own family
that's from somewhere else so that's a
good question for our listeners if you
have suggestions what do you you know
what might be a good suggestion and some
people might say look you know some
people don't think it's great to mix
ethnicities and to me they want and I
don't look I don't think there's
anything wrong with that either I don't
think there's anything wrong with it if
somebody wants to be traditional that's
fine
everybody you know it's like I think
it's kind of messed up in America it's
like
can have all types of different meetings
like you know Filipino you know jugglers
they can meet you know Mexican you know
kin Senora Papi's you know they can meet
you know black you know black railroad
you know mason party they could meet you
know you know Japanese ice cream lovers
can meet but the second white anything
wants to meet people say oh now that's
[ __ ] up I don't think that's [ __ ] up
I don't think I think it's like anybody
should be able to meet up if they're
meeting up for you know and they're over
there sharpening swords and [ __ ] they're
gonna come across the street and that's
kind of wack but but I think anybody
should be able to meet up and it should
have a group of the runner I know I went
off on a tangent but I think any of our
listeners nine eight five six six four
nine five zero three what suggestions
would you have for this what do you
think about it and um and it's okay
whatever your real thoughts are whatever
your you know if if you feel like it's
you know I think you know I think I
think whatever you know love is gonna
win so if you're really in love that's
probably gonna win out but how do you
love your grandmother oh sorry so full
of mucus right now oh I feel like there
is a [ __ ] odd or swimming in back and
forth between my nose and my throat
mmm and I don't want to keep eating it
or you're not eating it but you know
swallowing it but I do I'm sorry I'm
sorry
so there you go ninety five six six four
nine five zero three maybe some
suggestions for this young man but I
thank you for that call man and thank
you for you know wanting to know what I
think about it and yeah bet it's totally
different if you have someone of a
different ethnicity and you're bringing
in and just the bravery you're going
into as far as especially if that's a
first
you know person of a different ethnicity
that's being brought into your family
and your bloodline there's nothing wrong
with it but it certainly it is there
people the there's questions you you
have questions for yourself and you
think about that it's like you know cuz
people want to honor their own
bloodlines and they want to you know
they want to respect their elders and
for you know taking some of that into
account I think it's really interesting
I would love to hear what our listeners
think
here's another call right here they came
in nine eight five six six four nine
five zero three hey Theo my name is
Bobbi I'm 16
my parents have been married for about
40 years I have a older sister's about
30 she has two kids and a husband
another baby I'm aware the whole thing
Oh Bobbi I sound like you really have a
nice life going on you know you got your
parents your sister she's got the
children thank you for calling homeward
a dad around Christmastime started to
come out of gay and everyone okay so you
got that surprise gay at Christmas man
a jingle Bella do that right you hear a
[ __ ] jingle bell I don't make anybody
you know look over at another dudes nuts
brought us natural that's that you know
a jingle bell brought us a gateway drug
to meeting guys sometimes homeward I'm
famous that are involved in it a lot of
things that I got to think about a lot
of things that even questioned myself
and I don't know just if you have any
advice on that I would be great to hear
from you all right love you man thank
you love you too bro dang man wow that's
a lot yeah I think if my father had just
suddenly said look I'm gay
I'm like well damn you know pass the
[ __ ] pass the [ __ ]
red bra you know pass the butter cuz I'm
gonna need a roll if we're gonna chat
about that yeah you probably I mean it
yeah I mean especially if making you
question about or just think yeah I can
imagine different questions you know
could I be gay you might think you know
what does this do for my mother how does
she feel would she feel like you know
she's not enough which she just you know
I can imagine immediately you learn a
lot about different people in your
family and how they you know how they
think you know how they you know because
you have to be loving you have to be
supportive it's probably a really tough
thing for your dad cuz especially if you
struggle with that for a long time or if
he's just been afraid to say it or if
you didn't even know that was a thing
man dude there was points in my life
where I couldn't even meet any women for
so long I'll be like damn I must be gay
I must just be gay and not even know it
everybody might must be like damn do you
know he's out here keeps trying to meet
these ladies a man but he [ __ ] is
just gay and he doesn't know I thought
that I you know I got so in my head
about my just insecure and just didn't
know and and uh and just trouble in
relationships and stuff that I thought
that you know and I struggled especially
in my twenties with you know not getting
that bone or not getting that [ __ ]
nice woody and I would think
dang dude I must be you know homosexual
you know our homeowners that's what some
people call them you know or will say
hey man you know you don't want to be
rude or anything but you also you know
you want to know why you know these two
guys next to you keep looking at you and
drinking smoothies so you say oh these
guys right here you know they're
homeowners
man that would be such a shock if you
just found out I wonder if you knew did
you know how's your mom taking it you
know I think it's a great opportunity
for you to really be loving probably you
know cuz it's kind of wild it's like
usually it's like as young people we
need all the love but you know with your
dad going through this he's probably
gonna need you know some real moments of
support and just say you know this is
you know you really have a great moment
to be very powerful here and say hey you
know I love you dad and you know I just
you know I love you as a being as an
entity no matter what you know
essentially you prefer no matter if you
like you know whether you like you know
you like peaches or you like that
buffalo meat it's like I love you no
matter what you desire well no matter
what your palate prefers so that's a
great opportunity for you to do that but
dude I remember yeah I think a lot of
young dudes I remember I was so starved
for like connection with even just with
other males just to even have like
friends like and I had friends but I
didn't have a connection I did I never
felt you know I never I was so starved
honestly for like a father and a brother
for those elements in my life that had
been in my life but had never been him
but I've had never been in my life and I
was young that I remember sometimes even
I would see other dudes and I would want
to be friends so much or want to be you
know sometimes like a like a buddy of
mine would give me a hug or something
and it would just feel like so much more
to me I'd be like dang dog am I you know
I might be a straight-up home owner you
feel me brah might be [ __ ] you know I
might I might be confused I might need
to take out a second mortgage on myself
but the truth ended up being for me that
I just was so starved for connection you
know for male connection in my life
that when I got any of it it just it was
so I didn't realize how much I was
thirsting for it as much at a tan level
for a father for a brother that if I got
any you know connection from from a male
that it made me I just didn't even know
how to handle I didn't even know what
was going on but in the end I just
wanted you know I wanted my brother in
my life for I wanted a connection with a
father and so it but you know that kind
of stuff can be confusing and I don't
think that's what you're asking about
but I think it's a great opportunity for
you to be a loving son you know it's
wild man it's like a lot of our fathers
have grown up in these different times
because times have changed so much in
the past couple generations that you
know it's like we really have to be sons
we have to be you know we have to be
sons we don't know we don't just you
know we even though we're sweet
sometimes we feel like we didn't get
parented enough and we're not we can't
be kids we never even got to be a kid we
got to be we can be a son you know
sometimes my mother will call I don't
want to talk I don't want to you know
I'm uncomfortable I want somebody about
I know I'll you know somehow know if I
talk with her she's just gonna talk and
talk and I'm just kind of to listen but
at this point she's older now and I can
be a provider and I can be so I just
have to pick up the phone and be a good
son I mean those are little things I'm
learning am i telling anybody what to do
or something but I'm just trying to
relate to you and maybe I did and maybe
I didn't but that's the only relation I
have but I remember one time when I was
young this do Richard Langan Stein run
they called him bangin Stein because he
was a pity a file you know it you know
he preferred the company of children and
stuff around his wiener and stuff and he
would buy weed forever all the children
and he went to jail for this I'm not
accusing this man of anything he went he
got incarcerated on that and he go he
looked like Santa Claus bro and he had
that [ __ ] jingle bell you know he'd
hide a Jingle Bell in between his wiener
and his newts his balls and so you hear
that thing tank every now and then keep
you curious about his crotch
and and Richard what [ __ ] not talking
about Oh one time I was over at big
Richards they called him big Richard
because he biased these potatoes and
stuff and then get us high and [ __ ]
you know offer people a little bit of
that sour cream you know but but anyway
one time I was ever a big Richards and I
was high we had all been smoking out of
a Apple and one of this girl I knew in
my class her dad came over there with
another man and I'd been over at her
house at a party recently and seen her
dad and mom together in this daddy her
daddy was moonlighting around town with
this other guy named Hank with the man's
name and Hank boy I mean this dude was a
real homeowner bro he [ __ ] licked his
lips and he licked him more than he
should you know and you knew he was
doing something you know and he always
had his hand in his pocket or your
pocket or somebody's [ __ ] pocket sewn
on who just wear pockets on his hands
and just be like damn I do was always
reach him for ass even if he wasn't and
you know he just preferred the company
of men but I when I remember seeing her
father and I'd always thought I'd met
her father many times have been to their
home
this girl's dad she was in my school she
was in my grade and she didn't even know
she'd even know her dad you know was
living this double life you know this
double-edged sword with kind of men's
wieners on one side of it and and I
remember just blew my mind because I saw
him after that in this family element
and it was this whole different thing
and I never even told her and I don't
know if he came out of the closet
eventually and you know but it has to be
very uncomfortable for someone if they
want to be a certain way and they're not
and they can't live that way they don't
feel comfortable so there's probably
just a great chance for you to be a
really good son and be a cool son and um
and man I said you know it's a learning
experience you're going through right
now but just you know I don't know and I
don't know if you guys have a suggestion
for that young man you can hit the
hotline as well nine eight five six six
four nine five zero three and thank you
for that call
alright let's take another call
right here here we go I feel this is
Andrew calling in from beautiful San
Clemente California
oh hey Andrew I just met somebody this
morning I was eating breakfast at the
Cheesecake Factory and they had a couple
there from San Clemente and we chatted
for a little while and they were so nice
man they really made my morning let's
hear more you mentioned something about
how you sometimes you feel like your mom
which is talking ly was she would just
stop and you know I had to sit back and
laugh for a minute because I feel that
way too growing up in a household of
mostly women sometimes you just want
silence you know be alone with your
thoughts and that could seem impossible
but it's one which you know that there's
going to come a day where you may not be
able to hear her voice anymore or things
she says just don't make sense you know
I'm a caregiver for my 89 year old
grandmother has Alzheimer's and she was
basically turning into a toddler she
just sort of makes noises you know and
when she does put a sentence together it
doesn't make much sense
um there's days where she doesn't even
Remember Who I am
Wow so I hope you can remember that I
hope you take your own advice too
when you say she makes things about
herself sometimes we all do that we all
do that we need to focus on doing less
of it so I think again on touch it down
their nose no that's not a downer note
at all man I appreciate you saying that
you know that's exactly probably what I
needed to hear so I know that was a nice
you to call and say that and the way
that you said it you know here we'll
hear the New York all you're the first
voice I hear every Monday morning
so as you calling been thinking about
you gang man I appreciate it yeah that's
a nice man the way you presented that to
me was nice too
you know you presented that in a caring
way and I appreciate that dude
you're right you know you're right and
uh and I'm gonna keep that in my week
this week you know when when there's a
moment that I don't want to do something
because it's not I just can't deal with
it right now I'm gonna reframe it and
just say well you know yeah there may
come a time and I don't get to hear this
voice and and just yeah I mean reframing
it finding comfort in my mother's voice
the fact I even get to hear it as
opposed to the fact that it you know
grates against something in me that has
always been a little bit corrugated so
thank you I appreciate you saying that
man that's a nice message that's a
really nice message man I'm gonna try
that this week I'm gonna remember that I
don't remember you calling and telling
me tea at a pump a note to say Pompey
yes when I'm uncertain if if I'm feeling
comfortable or something and switch that
perspective if I can you know and I bet
I can I bet I actually can thank you for
that let's take one more call here nine
eight five six six four nine five zero
three what's up Bo gang gang this is Sam
from Washington gang gang Sam and thank
you for calling brother onward
in this past weekend we're pretty
excited about it
my wife gave birth to our second child
there you go you got that second one boy
you got that pet Pusa you know so that's
beautiful man congratulations welcome to
the world baby what a gift man I bet
that's beautiful Sunday morning I
couldn't think of a more peaceful time
to probably have a child more we named
him Theodore no Co for short and if that
freaks me out we didn't necessarily made
her after you my wife is doing the photo
theater and she doesn't listen to your
podcast but I have told her about you
it's a smart wife dude smart wife
homework
we're tired because were you know new
baby especially long she's pretty tired
but everybody's doing real well baby is
nice big @lc mom has healing and and
recovering well and his older brother
he's really excited to have a little
brother that's all and so hope to see ya
in the Portland area or maybe even
Seattle sometimes to have a good one
welcome to the world new little boy
Theodore I can tell you man it's gonna
be a tricky one brah
I'll tell you straight up being a
Theodore it can be tricky but um but it
sounds like you got an older brother
that's gonna be helpful you know and
that's what's interesting - when I think
what's interesting to me is when people
have you know children and two children
and you create brothers you don't even
realize that that's such a do the crazy
creation I try to whenever I'm doing
shows if I meet a pair of brothers
that's at the shows I tried to throw
them on my Instagram story and I just
love that you know I've just learned to
really love my own brother so much as
I've gotten older here especially in the
past couple years and just be so
grateful for that relationship it's like
you have this you know you have this
other person that has that has your
bloodline that has your your whatever
your that Native American that's inside
of you is in it the only other place
that exists the same way is inside of
him and even though it can be different
yeah brothers can be totally different
one of y'all might be cinnamon and one
of y'all might be salt but at the root
of that spice daddy Cemile are at the
root of that spice man that the only
other person that's gonna have that
magic mix they're the only other person
that's gonna have that magic mix and
that's a beautiful gift and I you know
it's the same for sisters and stuff I
can't relate that way but but
congratulations man welcome to the world
look Theodore people gonna call you the
adorable that's what I that's what I
like to say you know if I'm feeling good
I thought about coming out with a
product once called Theo sporran and
it's just a cream and you rub it on it
doesn't do nothing No
so but man you know think you think's
people for being a part of the episode
and for the calls and just for you know
this just weirdoes part we're just
living that's all we're doing and we did
it okay today and you're gonna do it
okay today I hope and I'm gonna do it
okay today
and if we think [ __ ] somebody man dude
[ __ ] them bro but also we can love them
do you know we can love somebody that's
completely [ __ ] up because we're
probably [ __ ] up to somebody and
somebody loves us so we can do it we can
do it you guys be good to yourself man
and we'll play this on the way out man
because I didn't really do it on the way
in but now I think it's kind of fits man
I'll see you guys as weekend Boston and
Medford Massachusetts over there at the
Chevalier theater on Thursday and Friday
I'll see you in the Wilbur man I can't
believe I'm gonna go to theaters this
weekend I'm one of the Borgata casino on
Friday do what is going on this is so
crazy
and I'm gonna bring a show man and I'm
gonna do it like I've never even [ __ ]
done it dude I might just hide my own
arms in my ass bruh we got this man
thank you guys for being a part of my
Monday and I hope you have a wonderful
week
I've seen old men about a hundred days I
can almost hear mama bleep for my
restless soul and now he made a dollar
night spell but where it's going ain't
kill me yet I still get wet I'm bound to
go
they control
[Music]
we're making a man we helping each other
make bacon back thank you guys so much
man
[Music]
got this [ __ ] be okay today put on that
neck brace dog and show up
[Music]
most all of my plans slip right through
my head around um
to me
[Music]
happy Mardi Gras down there in New
Orlean baby stops leaving I'm about an
hour past
but I'm banging it
[Music]
we're gonna do I think I'm gonna do a
meet-and-greet after the show and over
here in Boston we'll figure out how to
do it just do it in the dam wherever
[Music]
with making it
get out man this is South Aerosmith
right there man
Bishop gun don't sleep
[Music]
but I mean
and I wish I was a singer manatee : in
my dreams I am sometimes my dreams I
have a guitar and a harmonica you know